Ladies and gentlemen, we are back,
with Joe Manganiello,
(audience applauding)
Hello!
The star of "Archenemy".
Now, in "Archenemy",
you play someone who has so many questions about himself,
including whether he's a superhero or not.
And what do you want audiences to take away,
from their experience with "Archenemy"?
I want them to have many, many, many questions.
All the answers are there, but it's cryptic,
and you might need to watch the film a second time,
to pick up, you know,
the little nuances of little subtle hints,
our bread crumbs.
You know, yes, it is a story.
We meet this man who is homeless,
he lives in a tent under a bridge.
He's, you know, a drunken drug addict,
who's in a lot of pain.
He's crazy, delusional,
and he babbles on and on and on,
to anyone who will listen about how he was this like,
basically a superhero from another dimension,
a parallel universe,
that found his way to Earth, and lost his powers.
And no one believes him,
other than this one teenage blogger,
who's looking for content for his blogger pages,
and he starts recording these stories about my character,
Max, and they kind of go on this, you know,
adventure, together.
Short of, I mean, you know, it's basically like,
you know, story of redemption for my character,
trying to find his own purpose.
So, the question is, is he crazy,
or is he actually telling the truth?
Okay, now,
we have played this game on the show
with award-winning entertainers and Olympic gold medalists,
and now, we would love to play it with Bubbles, your dog.
We're gonna ask some rapid-fire questions,
and learn everything we can about Bubbles, in...
Bubbles in a Minute!
(upbeat music)
(laughing)
Oh, thank you, Joe, for playing.
Okay, here we go. Ready?
Okay. Does Bubbles prefer to walk or be carried?
Oh, well, she loves running, running, running, running,
but she loves being carried, too.
So, I don't know. It's kinda like 50/50.
Understood.
Bubbles, if you were starring in a movie,
who would she want to direct it?
Greg Jacobs, who directed "Magic Mike XXL".
You know, we did a road movie,
and it was like a buddy picture about, you know,
and I think that it's that kind of heart,
that Bubbles and I could do like a road movie,
directed by Greg.
What is Bubbles' favorite food?
I mean, she loves,
whenever I eat bacon, she loves bacon,
Who doesn't?
But she also likes jicama.
She has a nice, healthy jicama snack in the afternoon.
If Bubbles gets arrested, who is her one phone call?
Oh, me for sure.
It's all about Dada. She would call Dada for sure.
What do you hope is Bubbles' last thought,
before she goes to sleep each night?
I'm sure she's probably dreaming about her breakfast,
as soon as she goes to sleep.
(bell dinging)
Is she dreaming of a bacon jicama omelet?
(audience laughing)
Yeah, as gross as that sounds,
she would probably love that.
(Drew giggling)
Thank you so much, Joe Manganiello.
"Archenemy" is in theaters and on digital and on demand,
right now.
And of course, Bubbles, thank you so much.
And really, Joe,
it's been a real pleasure to talk to you today.
Thank you so much for coming on this show.
Thanks, Drew. It was great talking to you.
This was so much fun.
And like I said, I've been a big fan for a long time,
and, you know, thank you so much for having me on.
Thank you, Joe Manganiello!
(upbeat music)